Hi Internet !.
We need to talk about locks.
Physical and digital.
In the physical world, locks are not as good as you think.
The lock on your door stops the worries, not the thieves.
As two minutes of research will reveal to you.
Spend more, get more. But all this will fail with time and the right tools.
Kun physical locks are bad in the lock -
- Generally does not matter in normal life -
- Because thieves are tied to the material world.
The thief must walk around the neighborhood -
- Spend time to choose a goal -
- This makes a house look safe, cutting most of the way to be safe.
Every target house can attack -
- Once, it comes with the risk that the thief actually holds the material.
But the digital is different.
Physical restrictions no longer exist.
On the Internet, Loves a Digital Lock Protect you not only from the neighborhood thief -
- but of all thieves everywhere.
Because on the Internet there is nothing like distance.
Internet thieves do not penetrate locks personally.
They build a "thief" experimenting with millions of combinations -
- Just to see what will open.
A block away from you on the street, or a complete state on the other side of the world -
- The whole thing like.
Indeed, the other side of the world is better.
Someone in the East - Whatever - Steals Your Identity -
- Has the probability of zero percent convergence to hold.
This is bad news, but thanks to mathematics -
- Digital locks can be unbreakable.
This is encryption.
Digital lock, without password, can not be opened.
Thieves' programs will explore all possible possibilities -
- But a secure password will take -
- Longer than the heat of the universe to fade.
No password - no login
No matter how clever your mother is.
Your private files remain private.
This is probably the greatest social benefit that mathematics has given to people.
But it's easy to imagine a digital lock that does not open up as bad news.
The maximum calamity!
Time bomb, location and code disabled are locked in dead man's phone.
However, if the information were on a piece of paper -
- In a court room, no problem.
In the physical world, if you can not penetrate the lock -
- If the wall is breached.
The community agrees, under this scenario, it is reasonable for the police to intervene -
- No matter what it takes.
Note: This does not mean that the closure of the material world is only materially weak -
- but also legally weak.
It is possible to live in a world with special laws -
- Prevent police from breaking through all locks -
- Whatever the reason, we would not do because this would be an idiot.
Hmmm.
Here the gears start in the heads of governments by work.
If digital locks are physically impervious -
- Maybe it can make legally weak.
To require the digital locks to be built with a key hole that the police have its key.
Very protective -
- Very confidential -
- For emergencies only -
- With care.
This legal vulnerability to prevent citizens from owning digital locks is ideal -
- To require companies to manufacture key-hole devices -
- is the idea of ​​many governments interested in it.
Governments note that a memo allows police to enter your home and look at your papers -
- likes to let the police look at your phone.
If your home is fortified, but the need is urgent, the police come with a bang.
But there is no proof to open a closed phone -
- To comply with the note.
Not useful in any way.
This is a problem.
Once again, we all ideally want police to penetrate digital locks sometimes -
- But at our current level on the tech tree, the fact that there are digital locks that can not be opened is something that exists.
This is because they are made of mathematics, something a skilled programmer can build at home -
- Trying to prevent digital locks for everyone very close to trying to block an idea.
good luck-
- Try this.
But even if it is possible to prevent the perfect digital locks in a state successfully -
- Remember, on the Internet there is nothing like distance.
Even if your government is an exogenous bureaucracy like the landlord that can not be corrupted -
- There are demons elsewhere.
Unbreakable Digital Capability is the foundation on which computing and the Internet are built.
Exchange, purchase, blogging, video blogging, play, Twitter, fight, meet -
- All this is possible thanks to a non-breakable digital lock.
They have found since the computers filled the rooms -
- But with computers in our absence now -
- We rely on those locks to protect the content of our lives.
Content of our minds.
Intentional "weakness", even with the best intentions -
- Makes everyone at risk.
The nature of the hole is cracked to crack.
And the nature of the Internet that brings demons to the door.
Whatever we wish -
- There is no way to build a digital lock that only angels can open and demons do not.
Anyone who says otherwise is either ignorant of mathematics or is less angelic than what appears on it.